vaccine to receive who validation for
safety efficacy and quality
emergency listing contributes to vaccine
equity
by enabling countries to expedite their
own regulatory approval
to import and roll out vaccines
we encourage all vaccine manufacturers
who have not yet received emergency use
listing to contact who to discuss how to
accelerate
the process through rolling submissions
we continue to call on manufacturers of
vaccines that already have whi emergency
use listing
to prioritize kovacs not
shareholder profit
we continue to hear excuses about why
low-income countries have only received
0.4 percent of the world's vaccines
one is that low-income countries can't
absorb
vaccines that's not true
with the exception of a new a few
fragile conflict affected and vulnerable
countries
most low-income countries are ready to
go
the problem is simply that they cannot
get the vaccines
i repeat they cannot get the vaccines
another excuse from manufacturers is
that low-income countries have not
placed orders for vaccines
most low-income countries are relying on
kovacs
which has the money and the contracts to
buy vaccines on their behalf
but manufacturers have not played their
part
we still don't know when the
manufacturers will deliver
we continue to call on all manufacturers
to prioritize their contracts with
kovacs and the africa vaccines
acquisition trust or avat
no more vaccines should go to countries
that have already vaccinated more than
40 percent of their population
until kovacs has
the vaccines it needs to help other
countries
get there too
no more boosters should be administered
except to immunocompromise people
most countries with high vaccine
coverage continue to ignore our call for
a global monetarium on boosters
at the expense of health workers and
vulnerable groups in low-income
countries who are still waiting for the
first dose
we cannot end the pandemic without
vaccines
but vaccines alone will not end the
pandemic
vaccines do not replace the need for
public health and social measures
they complement them
distancing avoiding crowded spaces masks
ventilation hand hygiene
and other effective public health
measures remain important in every
country
every country must continue to adjust
and adapt its strategy
to support countries to do that who has
developed a tool called the intra-action
review
which countries can use to evaluate
what's working and what's not
more than 100 intra-action reviews have
now been conducted by 68 countries
several countries have conducted
multiple reviews
including south africa which has done 10
making it a central component of its
response
several key lessons emerge from these
reviews
the need for strong and active national
leadership at the highest levels
flexibility and adaptability by
adjusting and repurposing
existing systems guidelines and
resources
multi-sectoral cooperation
and in the case of vaccine rollout the
need for adequate cold chain capacity
and real-time monitoring of bugs in
stock
ending the pandemic as rapidly as
possible must remain the central focus
for every country
at the same time
we owe it to those who have lost their
lives to this virus to learn the lessons
it's teaching us
and take whatever action is necessary to
prevent a future disaster on this scale
the world was not prepared for covet 19
and we knew we were not prepared
in 2018
who and the world bank formed the global
preparedness monitoring board the gpmb
an independent panel of experts to
identify gaps in the world's defenses
and make recommendations on how to close
them
we did not know then when the next
global crisis would arise
or what it would be
but we knew that this is x would come
eventually
the gpmb published its first report in
september 2019
just months before the pandemic hit
it identified many of the
vulnerabilities that covet 19 has
exposed and exploited
the lack of political leadership and
commitment the lack of health system
readiness
the lack of trust with communities and
the lack of international cooperation
the second gpmb report released in the
middle of the pandemic last year
incorporated hard-won insights with
calls for predictable and sustained
financing
equitable access for vaccines and other
life-saving tools
and global governments for preparedness
the gpmb published its third report last
week
instead of making more recommendations
the gpmb is calling the world to act on
the recommendations it has already made
which are more relevant now than before
the pandemic but on which there remains
little action
we have no shortage of reports reviews
and recommendations
but we have a shortage of action
it's clear what needs to happen
better governance for global health
security
including a binding treaty on panamic
preparedness and response
better financing to strengthen the
capacities of all countries especially
the most vulnerable
better systems and tools to prepare for
prevent
detect and respond rapidly to outbreaks
with epidemic or pandemic potential
and a strengthened empowered
and sustainably fine established at the
center of the global health architecture
to say more about its latest report
i'm delighted to welcome my friend and
brother
mr
al-hajj asi
the gpmb co-chair and the former
secretary general of the international
federation of the red cross and red
crescent societies
asi
thank you for your leadership
and you have the floor
thank you thank you very much uh
my brother
i think i could build on
one of the very powerful sentence that
you just use
we need action we already know what we
need to do
what we need is action and action now
actually now because the window of
opportunity is closing by the day
so we need an urgency and we need your
ambition
you were absolutely right the report
after reports what we predicted happens
and we were congratulated to be right
and those were moments where it is not
nice to be right
what is it you know that we know what's
going to happen and we're smart enough
to predict it
i'm not
smart enough to take the action required
from preventing the outbreaks from
becoming pandemics
from preventing shock you know to become
disastrous
you mentioned the numbers
17 million relatedness millions of
people have lost their lives
millions more are without parents
or grandparents
well
to put it like we feel in the region i
am now
let me just say bluntly it is deeply
shameful
we should grieve we should be angry
because
millions of deaths is neither normal nor
acceptable
and these are just numbers that we're
quoting and we forget that
behind each unit of these numbers
there is a face
there is a human being there is a story
the story of a parent
of a child
of a friend of a colleague
many of them so we have lost in
ourselves being on the front line
and trying to respond to this challenge
the rift between halves and the half
nurse is growing
and you're right it's not just vaccine
equity
that should be
front and center
it is also a matter of how low-income
countries
are able to implement public health
measures
within their communities
and fragile economies to keep people
safe
we are indeed facing extraordinary
challenges and the world is clamoring
for solutions
yet globally the ship continues to step
back
and shy away from what needs to be done
we've seen it happen once again with the
recent g20 leader statement
honestly we had hoped
for firm financial commitments to fully
fund global efforts to keep the pandemic
we had hoped for an agreement to
establish a financing mechanism
that would provide predictable financing
at the scale required
to prevent further future pandemics
but what we got
with the commitment
to keep talking about it
we shouldn't be surprised
the world has exposed the world you know
that is covet 19 pandemic risk for the
world
that is inequal
divided in many instances and account
and accountable
through the pandemic polarization
geopolitical conflicts nationalism and
scepticism of multiple terrorism
have meant that many countries are
raising the drawbridge
rather than seeking global solutions
we shouldn't be surprised but we should
be dismayed
and we must demand more
we need to see signs that political
leaders are willing to work together
all political leaders
and take the ball steps that are
urgently needed to protect
the one and only planet we share
as well as the one and only humanity we
share
in our report we have challenged world
leaders to take five steps
only five
that would demonstrate their commitments
to change
and how they will go about it urgently
inclusively and equitably
five simple steps over the next eight
weeks that will give a clear signal to
the world
that they agree on what needs to be done
and are very serious about doing it
let me spell them out
first
agree at the november 2021 special
session of the world health assembly
on the need to adopt an international
agreement
on pandemic preparedness and response
and establish a process for taking
forward negotiations
second
agreed to convene a summit of heads of
states and government on pandemic
preparedness and response
together with other stakeholders and set
in motion a preparatory process for this
segment and i emphasize here
together with other stakeholders
because we've been experiencing a
multi-dimensional problem
that will require a multi-sectoral
approaching solution
third
agree to significant increase in wh
assessed contributions
in order to adequately and sustainably
finance the organization's essential
functions
and core capacities
year in and year out who has been
weakened
by less financing less authority yet
if things are not working
the fingers are being pointed towards
the blade show
that has to change
fourth
agreed to establish a new financial
intermediary fund for pandemic
preparedness and response and finally
develop terms of reference for the
design of an end
to end mechanism for research
development and equitable access to
common goods
is there a hope
yes
after years of inaction we are finally
finally seeing some traction on climate
change
world leaders gathered in glasgow this
week at cop26
are taking political responsibility and
making commitments for change
the current political context is
challenging but
there are some signs of progress
phonemic preparedness and response
should be a simpler problem in
comparison
so
why is it
so difficult to get world leaders in a
room to agree on the bold solutions
required
if covet 19
is not the catalyst for change
what will it be
it is easy to be cynical today and think
that nothing can change
that we are forever condemned to repeat
the cycle of panic apathy and neglect
but we must reject pessimism and
recognize our common humanity
and growing
interdependence we must recognize that
we live in a shared world with shared
risk
and shared responsibilities
the solutions must match the magnitude
of need
to bring this pandemic to an end
and to prepare for the next one
and even better prepare for the next one
and we must support those individuals
and organizations working tirelessly to
end this epidemic
many of them
or
some of the most important of them
gathered in this room today
were inducted to you
by brother dr dendros
and to the doublet show for the
leadership you continue to show
in working towards the global health
ecosystems
that serves everyone
everywhere
and that is the spirit you know in which
you know this report you know has been
published
and more than a report it should be
instant devising action and we continue
our mobilizations
in a frame of an independent framework
to see things happening
action be taken
and
accountability be shown thank you very
much
thank you thank you very much my brother
asi
i
will quote you from what you said
if kovid is not the catalyst for change
what could it be
that's really true
thank you
for your clear call to action and we can
only hope
that the international community
acts on that call
as you said
we know what needs to happen
what we need now is action
urgency
and ambition thank you so much again for
your leadership
tariq back to
you um thank you dr teddrus thank you mr
asi mr c will be with us uh
throughout this press conference and uh
we'll be available to answer some of
your
questions with this we will open the
floor for questions from journalists who
are online and we will start immediately
with nina larson from afp nina
yes hi thank you very much for taking my
question um
as you mentioned the world this week
passed uh the devastating milestone of
five million
officially registered kova dust since
the start of the pandemic
um at the same time we're seeing
case numbers rising in many places
including europe which now appears to be
the epicenter of the pandemic again as
dr kluge said today
as we approach the end of the year i was
wondering if you could say how you
expect this pandemic to evolve into
if you think there is any chance at all
the pandemic could be declared over next
year or are we instead looking at a
worse thing possibly even the doubling
of this death toll thank you
thanks very much for the question i'm i
will begin on i'm sure others may want
to come in um
i mean the i just i just hope that
marking this tragic milestone doesn't
become just that that it's just another
number
um that we reach
i don't think the world has even begun
to grieve
this many deaths and we know it's it's
far far higher and every single one of
us on the planet has been impacted by
this pandemic the trajectory of this
pandemic
is in our hands
it has always been in our hands
and your question about what will happen
into 2022
remains up to us
is there a possibility where we can
reach a state where we have gained
control over transmission
in 2022 absolutely
is there the possibility that we can
remove
the death the severe hospitalizations
and death in 2022 absolutely we could
have done that already
but we haven't
and collectively
as
individuals as leaders
we have to take
stock of that and make a choice and make
conscious choices every day of how we're
going to address that
you ask about 2022 and it's a good
question we get that question a lot but
right now
we are seeing
increases where we shouldn't be
you mentioned europe
there's been a 50 more than 55 percent
increase in cases over the last four
weeks in europe where there's ample
supply of vaccines where there's ample
supply of tools and you know
we mentioned grieving and being angry
and being frustrated what we need to see
is that anger that emotion turned into
action
we need actions that percep protect
ourselves that protect our loved ones
from infection from the spread
we need leaders to provide communities
with consistent accurate information
to enable communities to keep themselves
safe and their loved ones safe to invest
in systems and surge those systems for
surveillance for testing to support our
health workers
it's happening now we can't make these
changes once this pandemic is over to
prepare for the next one
one of the themes of today is these
interaction reviews
and many countries have used this to
assess where they are and to make
necessary changes and that is something
we advise to countries to regularly
assess the epi situation the severity of
the situation in their country and the
capacities that they have and to course
correct where needed this is a strength
this is not a weakness of countries so
the question is not what we do in 2022
it's what we do right now
and we have the opportunity and we have
to do this now how many more people need
to die
how many more countries need to be put
into severe situations again before we
take action
so everyone that's watching this whether
you're an individual whether you're a
journalist and thank you for putting out
good information through your networks
leaders
what will you do today
um
mr el hajj asi would you like to add
something on on this particular question
on the prospects
really not just to reinforce i think
that maria from karkov studied
you know very nicely
it is the anger and the emotion should
not paralyze us
it should lead you know to action and
the resurrection you know that we all
are hoping
let's get inspiration i think from the
thousands
and tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of people on the front line
who are confronted you know with these
challenges on a daily basis
and doing their best to alleviate human
suffering and to save lives
let us think of you know those who have
hosted the virus in their own bodies
including myself
were very very sick and then knowing
what it means
you know to have health care workers you
know on your side
and to know how an oxygen tastes
you know to save your life
and all the things that we're talking
about is not abstract all these things
we're not talking about
are realities you know on a day to day
that we are all facing and then
confronting
so um
again
we will continue to express you know
this anger to continue to express these
emotions
but
emotions means to be in motion to be in
action
and that is you know that partnership
that we are calling for and will
continue to to do so every day
thank you very much uh
mr asi we will go now to next question
shoko koyama from japanese broadcaster
nhk
choco the floor is yours
hi sir can you can you hear me uh yes
nice to see you again uh regarding
kovacs in which uh which issues an
emergency news listing yesterday i was
following the social life generally
yesterday the heart the explanation on
which strain has been used
i understood it is closer to the
original strain but not delta strength
but didn't quite understand how who
considers the effectiveness towards
variance so was it
found to have 78 percent efficacy
against kobit 19 of any civility
including delta variant
and my second question if i may
what impact do you consider this
approval gives to increase the capacity
of distribution with kovacs facility
thank you
thank you maybe doctor swaminathan may
start
and also dr rigeria can add
yes i can start i'm sure dr gaspar will
come in so
um yes as you heard the who
did provide the emergency use listing
yesterday to kovacson that's the latest
and this process is ongoing we have a
rolling submission
we look at
the committee looks at efficacy and
safety data from all of the clinical
trials and also post marketing
surveillance studies as well as the
manufacturing itself the quality of the
manufacturing
sage which is the
independent strategic advisory group of
experts on immunization also looks very
carefully at the clinical trial data so
what uh was said was that
this vaccine the corvaxin
in its trial of about 25 000 people the
phase 3 trial of adults over
18 years had an efficacy of about 78
against symptomatic
infection and at the time that the trial
was being done in india there was a lot
of delta
it was around the time that the delta
virus was becoming predominant virus so
in the trial
when they did the genotyping of the
infected participants they had people
with delta infection they also had
people with previous variants like alpha
so when they looked at the subgroup
of delta infection they found that it
also had a fairly good efficacy of
close to 70 percent i think it was
around 68
so that's why
the clinical trial um data actually
shows overall efficacy of 78 a higher
efficacy against severe disease
close to 90 percent but the number of
cases
were less so that's why the confidence
intervals are quite wide
and they also were able to give an
estimate of the efficacy against
the delta variant because some of the
trials that were done for other vaccines
were done at a time where the delta was
not the predominant
variant and then subsequent studies had
to be done
to
to find out you know the efficacy
against a different variant so it's
always good to have that
information as well
from the
manufacturers what emergency use listing
provides is a couple of things one is
that
it enables countries to regulatory
agencies to approve very quickly based
on the whol because they can
many countries go by by the whol or
pre-qualification
and therefore it provides opportunities
for expanded use and access uh of this
product
and it's basically a stamp of
safety efficacy quality and and
hopefully it also enables people
for
easier travel
as many countries are looking at
at vaccination certificates even though
the who continues
to uh say that vaccine certificates
should not be the exclusive
criterion for travel entry
rogerio might want to add
so thank you samia just to compliment
because i think you covered already part
of the the question
just to compliment on the procedure for
approval which was
in the media with several questions in
in weeks before this one and
now the process is completed we can go
to the numbers and to the facts as we
normally wish to do so
the approval of the eight vaccines that
were e-weld since the beginning
varied between 40 to 165 days
specifically kovacsine the bharat
vaccine was submitted on 9th of july and
approved on the 3rd of november which
means 120 days by the clock but we if
you consider the relevant data that was
submitted by the end of july it's closer
to 90 days in terms of the process of
approval i hope these numbers which are
transparent and they are in the website
of who as we normally do every week
put an end to a number of questions that
we have seen in the previous weeks thank
you
many thanks um
now we will go to the next question
that's uh donato mancini from financial
times donato
hi everyone thank you so much for taking
my question um
can you just speak a bit louder
hi sorry so i know i know you've been
asked about the trajectory of the
pandemic in 2022 but what is your
assessment of the situation
in europe currently with cases rising
especially in eastern europe and
in benelux where your restrictions are
being imposed among other places thank
you so much
so i can begin i mean i think you know
as we are seeing cases and deaths
increase across large parts of europe
it's not just in eastern europe but in
many other countries as well our
recommendations are really to use
the tools that you have to act fast
to use public health and social measures
in addition to increasing vaccination
coverage um and to tailor the response
as locally as possible um understanding
what the situation is um because it is
diverse it's not the same
we don't give prescriptive information
or
advice because the situation is so
dynamic
and capacities are also different
and so our recommendation is to assess
you know where you are with the epi but
when you're looking at cases what we do
see is in countries that have access to
vaccine the vaccines are incredibly
effective against hospitalizations and
against deaths so you may see cases case
numbers increasing but the deaths are
not increasing at the same rate
the fact that there still are people
that are are dying needs to also be
addressed of course um and part of this
is ensuring we have adequate vaccination
coverage in all countries of those who
are most at risk people with underlying
conditions those who are over the age of
60 and critically are front line workers
but in addition to that even if you are
vaccinated to continue with the public
health and social measures
continue to wear a mask a well-fitting
mask over your nose and mouth mask
supplies are ample now
and this is
perhaps an inconvenience for some but
this is one of the proven measures that
can limit the spread in addition to
physical distancing avoiding crowds
working from home as much as you as much
as you can not everybody has that luxury
um and for leaders to really invest in
in surveillance and build up those
capacities and systems right now
um it's about a combination of approach
it's not just vaccines it's vaccines and
not vaccines only
and so
what we need for countries to do is to
really stay the course you've heard us
say that before and what that means is
to apply a number of measures some
people like the swiss cheese analogy of
building and layering upon
and adjusting that and tailoring as
needed
and we're here to support we support
through our regional offices through our
country offices
to help with supply if necessary you
know to ensure that there's adequate
clinical care and
we will continue to do that
many thanks dr van kerkov we go to next
question gunila von hall from svenska
douglas
you have the flow
uh yes can you hear me
very well
thanks for taking my question um
it is about europe and the situation
cases going up in europe is now again we
heard today epicenter of the pandemic
um at the same time
same week we have the g20 in rome we
have the climate summit in glasgow with
30 000 participants
how wise is this
how advisable is it to have big
international meetings in person when we
have this situation especially in europe
right now
thanks
um i i think um
both of those um
gatherings that you you mentioned have
very strict protocols in place in terms
of the
the status that
the participants have had to demonstrate
before attending those conferences and
we've been supporting many
[Music]
mass gatherings over the last two years
and in trying to ensure that we can
continue to gather safely
in reduced numbers virtually and
increasingly face to face um i i do
think uh though that in referring back
to what maria has spoken about
the the reality for for europe
in general
is that we've had that again and it's
we're two years into this but we seem to
be constantly surprised
by the the simple behavior of viral
pathogens um
we have
come out of a summer period with
increased mixing
increased mobility increased gatherings
a lot of restrictions have been reduced
the onus has been put back on
individuals to continue individual risk
management with little support from the
governments in being able to to continue
doing that
temperatures have dropped
it's the weather has disimproved and and
people
are moving back inside
and they're doing that in two contexts
in the context of
countries that have relatively or very
high vaccination levels in vulnerable
groups but transmission has been
transferred into younger age groups so
you have intense transmission without
necessarily a huge increase in in in
hospitalizations and deaths
and then you have other scenarios in
which there's been relatively low
vaccine uptake in some countries and
they're really facing into a very
difficult situation because they have
sub-optimal vaccine coverage and there
are countries in europe who have this
there may be plenty of vaccine available
but uptake of vaccine has not been equal
and uptake of vaccine particularly
amongst highly vulnerable groups so when
you look at coverage of vaccination in
any country and say it's 60 percent for
me i want to know which
who's covered if you've got 95 or 99
percent of people over 65 with
underlying conditions covered then
clearly you're not going to have the
same risk
if if half of your vulnerable population
are still not covered with vaccine then
they remain extremely vulnerable in a
context of increasing intensity of
transmission
the other factor i think that's not
really
i think being considered is health
systems have already been weakened by
this massive effort over the last 22
months health workers are exhausted many
health workers are leaving the
profession
and
hospitals
around europe were just getting back
with doing elective work and the normal
work and now we're seeing country after
country having to switch back to
canceling
elective surgery or non-essentials
medical interventions and having to
reprogram back to
shoring up their intensive care and
their high support care
facilities this is again putting a lot
of pressure back on health workers so
even where we're not seeing the same
increases in hospitalizations as we saw
um earlier in the year
a smaller number of cases is placing an
even greater burden on the system
because the systems are tired the people
in the system are tired
they're still fighting very hard but
it's very hard
for them to to to be able to react in in
the same way it is very difficult to
sustain
the kind of effort that's needed on
everyone's part
on the part of health workers on the
part of communities and the parts of
government there's exhaustion and
exhaustion is leading to complacency and
complacency is leading to gaps in our
system gaps in testing
gaps in clinical management
gaps in vaccination and it is through
those gaps
that we see transmission it is through
those gaps that we see the
hospitalizations and the debts and we
need to close the gaps
we need to close the gap in vaccination
we need to close the gap in protected
safe well-rested health workers we need
to close the gap in protecting ourselves
and through public health
measures as maria has said wearing mass
and being cautious
just because you're a vaccinated does
not mean you're perfectly protected
against every outcome um in in in covert
uh in covet 19. so
and and you know the numbers are are
also debts are also rising in other
regions and cases are rising in other
regions and and
it's very important to reflect that
europe represents over half of the
global cases in the in the last week
but that trend can can turn look what
happened we're we're all epidemiologists
now we only have to look at the roller
coaster epidemiologic curve to know that
when you're coming down the mountain
you're usually about to go back up
another one and the fact that europe is
climbing that mountain again should
really stand everybody up around the
world and say what are we going to do
because
europe does have the capacity and
european countries have the capacity
they have the
vaccine access they have the money they
have the systems in place that they can
react many other regions don't
necessarily have those capacities in
place so i think it's a it's a it's a
it's a warning shot for the world to see
what's happening in europe despite the
availability of of of vaccination
and i think we all have to double down
and recommit ourselves to doing
everything we can to be the last person
in the chain of a transmission
and
that's going to mean
i think
increased use of
of for example things like antigen
testing and expanded changing the way
and
we were discussing this this morning
sometimes
to stay the course you have to change
course
and at the moment we seem to be
hell-bent on a course that says the
pandemic is over and we just need to
vaccinate a few more people and this
will all be over that is not the case
we need to and maria spoke to this each
and every country now needs to look at
its strategic preparedness and response
plan for this pandemic it needs to look
at the gaps in the system that exists
right now and it needs to plug those
holes in their response
some countries are going to need a lot
of assistance with that many european
countries are well able to
to deal with that and i know governments
don't want to disappoint their
populations by going backwards
and there's this perception that we're
moving forwards now towards the end of
the pandemic and any step backwards is a
retrograde step i think every country
now needs to look at its epidemiology
look at protecting its health workforce
or its health system
and ensure that it can get through the
next few months without systems going
into collapse again and that will
require in in many countries a course
correction
and a real focus on ensuring that every
single vulnerable person is has had a
full vaccination
thank you dr ryan next question
he's coming from mexico mexico and we
have emmanuel lino with us
online emmanuel could you please
mute yourself and
ask your question
yes thank you very much
my question is well i read that
an article in the bmg that says that who
is needed
now more than ever but is handcuffed by
lack of funds and structure that leaves
it vulnerable to politics
these problems can be fixed
says the author and must be on urgently
uh could you share some thoughts on this
statement
thank you
maybe mr rc could start as he was
mentioning about funding and then we'll
come back to the room here
mrs yes i
personally have a witness in my
professional
lifetime
you know that when we were confronted
with a huge hiv epidemic
not enough was university in double hero
but we created units and i work for unh
i also remember very well you know after
the ungass in 2001
when we needed to invest more on htb and
malaria
we did not invest more in double sho but
we created the global funds
also with nurse you know when gravity
was created
when we needed to do more on
immunization
and most recently we saw the creation of
stop tv partnership
robot malaria partnership
maybe there is a good intention behind
all of that
you know to call for a multi-stakeholder
multi-sectoral response to these
challenges you know that we see
but at the end of the day
if any of those sectors did not deliver
and at the end of the day we had some
problems and issues
at the country level or the local level
fingers are be pointed at doubleho
so when we call for greater funding for
who
more support
more accountability and more authority
this is not the favor that we are doing
to the nhl it is not because we care
about global health
and we care about the support that is
required and that needs to be given not
to countries
we believe that a much stronger funded
public show
with greater authority
out of you know the geopolitics
positioning
will be the way to go and that
can also
make the organization you know more
accountable and then we can all be no
more demanding
using a video organization
we only hope you know that with this
current crisis
we do not repeat you know the same if
not mistakes but you know the common
practices
that again
let's try
you know to see outside of double it
show what we can do
and then
continue to blame dublin show if things
are not working so we
strongly believe that a stronger
doublehead show fully funded that
pleasure with greater authority
that comes with greater accountability
is something that is required now and
urgently
um
let me just add to ice's
comments um
again i would
put when we speak about who is the world
health organization against
some people
uh imagine that as a secretariat
building in geneva switzerland the world
health organization
is effectively the combination of 194
member states around the world
who come together to agree on what
priorities should be for health and what
policy should be for health it is our
work as a secretary under the leadership
of dr teddrus to implement those
policies and implement the will uh of of
countries in terms of what uh countries
consider to be the priorities uh in
terms of of health um
it's
in my view
uh the way we're we're dealing with our
transnational health issues at the
moment is we're trying to deal
with a a global threat using
individualized solutions i was on a
a
foresight roundtable this morning and
professor alice roberts who many of you
will know was was on that round table
and she's a medical anthropologist and
communicator and said that we're
effectively operating a medieval feudal
system where each country can build its
own castle and pull up the drawbridge
and that represents safety
that concept may have worked in medieval
times it doesn't work in the face of a
globalized viral
pathogen and it doesn't work when we
talk about other issues in healthcare
like hiv or tb or malaria we need
collective solutions we need trans
national what would be called
multilateral
solutions we need agreement at a global
level on what is to be done to protect
the health of the world's population
health for all
you can't deliver health for all unless
you prioritize health for all and when
we talk then about putting more money
into health it's not about putting more
money into who are more funding into who
it's about putting more funding into
healthcare systems into public health
systems into protecting health that
local community national and global
level who can do its part but the the
the main investment here and i'm sure dr
teddrus would speak to this is investing
in universal health coverage investing
in public health systems at national
level
epidemics and pandemics begin and end in
communities the deaths we've seen in
covet have primarily been due to
unmanaged underlying health conditions
that people have
borne for years and years without proper
access to health care be it for
financial reasons ethnic reasons many
other reasons
so yes there needs to be a massive scale
up in funding in the in the in the space
of health health is not a cost health is
an investment
and
no more than with uh with with climate
change it cannot be addressed through
single country responses that can only
be addressed when we all come together
and invest in health and health for all
and in that sense yes i would agree that
with i see there
clearly who has a huge role to play in
that but the real gap here is investment
in in health and healthcare systems and
health protection
many thanks uh dr ran and mr asi we have
a time for one maximum two questions we
also want to hear at the end from dr uh
levi ledrasko on the
uh on the interactive exercises on the
preparedness so let's uh go to john
zarracostas from the lancet john
yes good afternoon on a cloudy geneva
day uh my question is to some of the
participants on the panel and in
particular
mr alhaj
you mentioned you would like to see an
international instrument
and for
some guidance going forward on the
negotiations and dr tedros also
mentioned that
can you please elaborate a little bit
and make the case why it's so important
given you had the international health
regulations negotiated at five over five
years and ignored in the first few
months of the pandemic so can you please
make the case and since mr al hajj is
there i'd love his views also on the
epidemic of indifference right now
worldwide on the catastrophic food
insecurity in madagascar in yemen in
afghanistan
thank you john mr asim
thank you very much now let me uh
you know go back you know to the initial
recommendations you know that were made
that were based on
the confrontation of really what is
lucky
and we realized there are so many
instruments already existing
you know they cover certain areas and
then work well for that purpose
you know when we are now facing a
pandemic of an unprecedented magnitude
we will need responses and instruments
you know that are at the same level and
same scale
not only for this pandemic but you know
for similar cases that we will be
confronting
in the future and many
like myself believe that it is not a
question of if it is only the question
you know of when
now
we have already said that the world is
in crisis we say the world is fragmented
we say there is a lack of leadership we
say there is a lack of accountability
how can we
you know make sure you know that all
those lacks you know that we're talking
about can be remedied and then we find
systems and framework that is bringing
people together
you know for action or monitoring and
for holding each other accountable
and that is the reason why
you know we are supporting pretty much
that instrument
be the convention you know be it a
treaty you know that would be defining
you know roles and responsibilities
there of countries and include
a high level monitoring framework of
member states at the highest level you
know to make sure that we hold each
other accountable
if that is not defined
in a form of a treaty that commits
states you know to do something then you
don't have a
basis upon which that accountability can
also be exercised
and that is the reason why we are
supporting it and
there are many activities already going
on many negotiations many discussions
this is not
in layer of the ihr
this is not you know a substitution you
know two
but it is an instrument that is you know
much more transversal you know that we
believe that will also reflect the
multi-sectoral and multi-dimensional
issue of the kind of problems you know
that we are talking about a parallel
discussion on the ihr is certainly
happening to draw lessons you know from
what have been learned so far and then
further strengthening
we will be living in a world that is not
going to be a matter of either all or
how these different instruments will be
complementing each other and taking
action out to another scale the issues
that we were mentioning you know in
yemen in madagascar and others all that
again
you know has been revealed now by of 19
and when we talk about
strong leadership active citizenship
common humanity finding solutions you
know to the problems you know of the
people on the ground all that come
together and i think that is the reason
why i was starting by saying
an outbreak should not be a pandemic a
shock and a hazard should not be a
disaster that could apply for food
security that could apply for the
climate that could apply also for
epidemics and i think that is that
common platform of leadership and
accountability that is required
and it is pretty much illustrated by the
covet 19 pandemic
many thanks mr c uh
maybe as we are nearing the the hour of
this press briefing uh we could give a
flaw to dr libya vladivasco to tell us
more about those intra-action
reviews that have been uh taking place
in a number of countries
um
that have been mentioned in opening
remarks doctor
thank you thank you derek
many speakers called for course
corrections course adjustment and global
action
and while
perhaps
it is difficult to
prompt these actions at the global level
at the local level and subnational level
interaction reviews do exactly that they
identify what needs to be corrected in a
particular locality and as dr general
mentioned a hundred interaction reviews
have been done at country levels and
many countries found
value in them and are repeating them
10 interaction reviews in south africa
many interaction reviews in new zealand
and many other countries countries see
value in targeted interaction reviews
they're looking at their vaccination
efforts they're looking at their crisis
communication efforts
so i want to also commend many countries
that are choosing to publish their
interaction reports on their government
portals this promotes transparency
accountability and sharing of their
strengths and challenges with their
populations and with their neighbors
thank you
thank you dr
just to uh let everyone know that we
have been also joined by
dr landry maggiane who works with dr
drasco in country simulation exercise
and reviews i don't know if dr landry
would like to add something on this
topic
yeah thank you thank you so much for for
this opportunity
it's just again to uh
to reiterate on the need for continuous
learning
because it's only when we are learning
and we are able to identify where the
gaps are and
course correct and apply those lessons
learned this is the best way we can
we can really address this pandemic as
quickly as possible and and i believe
interaction review can play a critical
role in that and i really urge countries
uh as uh dr maria van gaal uh sorry
doctor maria like mentioned at several
occasions we need really to learn
and and and and apply the critical
lessons learned as we move forward over
many thanks uh dr landry uh so maybe
before i give a flow to
uh to to dr teddres uh dr ryan would
like to add something
just uh on the on the the issue of
instruments and and treaties just uh i'm
sure people are aware of this but uh
the world health assembly will convene
at the end of this month
with dr teddras
for only the second time in its history
in an extraordinary meeting to consider
one issue one agenda item one agenda
item only and that is the
the need
for and the merits of
concluding a new agreement or framework
treaty convention
uh that would allow the world to react
uh collectively
uh
in preparedness and response to to the
next pandemic that will be led by our
member states as i said in my previous
intervention
and it's going to be a very important
convening of all the member states of
who with the director general to
consider that very very question and
i think it's a very very important
moment in the history of global
public health and as the director
general has said before
a generational moment to consider the
future of pandemic preparedness and
response
thank you dr ryan so i will just go back
to uh mr alhaj i see for any final
remarks before we give a flow to dr
peters
thank you very much just one final
remark again to
thank the blitz show and the world bank
for convening the gpmb
and to stress again the importance of an
independent monitoring framework you
know moving ahead with uh
all these negotiations going on all
those ideas on the table including a
trade euro convention and again
monitoring calling for action
incentivizing for action and holding
people accountable so the gpmb is
committed to that and we'll be looking
forward to not to continue working with
all of you in that trigger thank you
very much
thank you very much for your
participation and very strong messages
today mr rc
with this will conclude a press briefing
the
audio file will be sent shortly and
transcript will be available tomorrow
last floor is as always for dr tetris
thank you
thank you tariq i i think it was a very
important pleasure and thank you asi for
for joining us and your message was very
clear
we know what to do
now it's it's time for for action i
think
that would be the best message to take
from today's presser and
move
forward to take action
and immediate being
vaccination
as you know we have
a 40 target
of vaccination
for each and every country
by the end of this year
and that's possible so i would like to
use this opportunity to call on
those who can afford to to
share
and also support in any other way
and also cooperation from the
manufacturers
to achieve the
40 percent target
so i think that's a clear goal and where
our action should should be focused
among other things
of course the long term is key while
fighting the pandemic now we need to
prepare for the long term
and that's why um as mike said we
are now going to have a special session
of the world health assembly at the end
of this month to discuss
the need for pandemic treaty
this pandemic has been really
unprecedented
and
if i will again quote asi
if this coveted pandemic cannot be a
catalyst for change
it's very difficult to change to to
understand
what
could be actually
a catalyst
so
that's why
the treaty
the discussion or the assembly
to discuss the treaty is is very
timely very crucial
and i hope the world will will agree to
have
a treaty or agreement
that can help us to fight the next
pandemic in a better in a better way
so thank you so much again to asi for
your leadership and thank you also to
the media for joining us today
and see you next time
you